we're gonna start with some questions
that we got from YouTube sure we have
one that came in from que puta and que
rights how were you able to juggle a
production company through high school
and university and still be a comedy
legend all those years Wow that's all
news to me
oh legend um I mean when I was a kid I
started my first production company and
it was maybe nine or ten boys destiny
productions
no like it was making movies making
little videos with my friends was my
hobby like it's what I did like when
other kids were playing soccer or
kissing girls like I was making little
movies with my friends and as I got
older as I got in high school I found
fellow friends who wanted to make movies
and we formed a production company even
just to make we made a feature in high
school you know we made three features
by the time I went to college over the
summers and from a young age I knew that
I wanted to make movies and work in in
creative entertainment fields and and
like I couldn't imagine doing anything
else
and so like starting my own company that
started as a goof and then actually I've
johnny voodoo Productions which I
started like as a goof in high school it
now is Mike my actual LLC production
company that I used to make stuff I just
maintained it ever since and and and
yeah I guess I've just always kept that
going because it's like I have jobs to
make money but then also for fun or as a
creative artistic outlet like there's
the stuff I do over here and luckily we
live in an industry we're working in an
industry where sometimes we can even
make those things overlap I don't know
if that answered your question at all I
think it's K as a question but I think
that does ya know you talked about you
grew up in I'm sorry I should just say
it nollans not
it's New Orleans we don't like knowing
when you spell it in awl IMS it's trying
to be cool no backfire yeah but so you
were from born and raised in New Orleans
on the bayou
not really the bayou but yeah I grew up
right on the other side of the
Mississippi River like from the French
Quarter and yeah like growing up in New
Orleans was it really I didn't realize
how unique it was like while I was
growing up because I just thought every
city was like this so I go every city's
got it super old and you have Mardi Gras
right I didn't really I don't know I
just didn't understand its uniqueness
until later on when I left and I was
like oh that's a pretty cool place and
the whole city has a vibe of like
creative energy and really supporting
you know creativity and and I loved it
and there's like a supernatural sort of
medium oh yeah everything's haunted
anywhere you go
there's some spirit and doing something
nice hopefully behaving hopefully you
should use you pretty good okay okay
well that's the holding ready world is
like anywhere you go and be like hey see
that house over there it's like a
hundred 80 years old and bunch of people
died in that house okay cool but now
it's a dentist's office sure now it does
root canals okay so then we have one
here from Nate's film tutorials
I need how did you go about starting
your own production company and what
advice would you give to those who are
starting out so we kind of talked about
that yeah I mean all you got to do is
start a production company as a register
with the city and then you have a
company but then it's just like then you
actually have to go do stuff you know
then you have to make stuff and you know
like I live in Los Angeles no matter
where you live you find the creative
people in your city and you just kind of
like get to know them and hang out with
them and become friends with them and
it's amazing you know even going to a
barbecue like it's a friend's birthday
barbecue and you go and you start
talking to people like so what do you do
you're like oh I'm a composer oh cool
like I actually have been looking for a
composer and then you get their card or
you get the information the next time
you need a composer you met that person
at a barbecue and you know that they
often say like in the movie business
it's who you know right but that doesn't
just mean like your family connections
or something it's just like who you know
like socially in life you know because
you into a barbecue and you met a
composer and then part of like having a
production company or making stuff is
just knowing people in all fields it's
not just you know like as a writer I sit
at home in working in my laptop by
myself but like if you want to actually
produce stuff and have a production
company you need to know people in all
the fields you need to know sound people
you need to know composers you need to
know craft services people like you have
to just get out and and like be
introduced to people in all fields so
that when it come times to make
something if you have a production
company that make stuff you need to be
able to call anyone in any position and
if someone's like hey do you got you
have a trance trance po guy like someone
who drives trucks you're like yeah I
know three I know three people I could
call it right now you know and that's
really helpful
you have to force yourself to get out
sometimes oh yeah yeah I like to be an
isolationist isolationist often but also
like just trying to get on set in any
capacity even you know when I was
younger I was just a PA on set and you
just meet everybody you meet the craft
services person you meet the Transpo
guys you meet the hair and makeup people
and you become friendly with them and
you get to know them and then you know
so much of production is just referrals
you know the DP is working on a new
project and that project needs craft
services and he's like oh I know a
person that I met on my last thing here
why don't you call them and so I mean I
love being on set like I love directing
and being on set and like it's so much
fun that to me that's that's almost like
networking right is just being on a set
and like meeting everybody because some
directors will go on a set and just not
talk to anybody but their ad or like the
actors you know but then but I'm someone
who like on the first day I try to
introduce myself to everybody I want to
know who the Transpo guys are like I
want to know every art department person
like what is their name and get to know
them all and become Facebook friends at
them and cuz maybe we'll work together
again maybe I'll need you or you'll need
me who knows how did you get a
screenwriting agent right after college
was it I went to the University of Texas
and they used to do this thing called
The Hollywood showcase where they would
take an hour's worth of student films
and they would show it out here in LA at
the DGA theater and they would invite
alumni alumni alumni of the university
just to come and see the short film just
to see like what are the kids doing back
at school and so the year I graduated I
had written I'd written a short film
that played and I had written and
directed another one side too including
a puppet short that ended up becoming
the inspiration for the happy time
earners but so I was you know living in
Austin I was delivering pizza I was
gonna move to Chicago and do second city
and then you go to New York because you
know I grew up thinking like LA like
Hollywood like sella what am I going to
sell out and and so they picked two of
my short films to play at this thing and
I graduated like on Saturday a couple
days later like I came to LA just to go
to the screening just cuz I'd never been
LA before and I just graduated I was
like
to the Hollywood Walk of Fame I'll go to
the beach and so I go to the screening
and there was an agent at the screening
who just happened to go to my college
and he was just there to see the shorts
and he liked my short film so much that
he walked up to me at the reception
afterwards and said hey I loved your
short film have you written any features
before cuz I'm a literary agent I
represent writers and I said well I
wrote one for class like I took a
screenwriting class and he's like oh
we'll send it to me I'd love to read it
and I was like sure so I got his card
and I went back to Austin and I mailed
it to him this is Beck back in the day
were you mailed people things and I just
kept living pizza saving up money to
move to Chicago and then a couple months
later he called me and he just said hey
we've read your script and we love it we
want to sign you and represent you as a
writer but you have to move to Los
Angeles you can't move to Chicago
because we want to be able to send you
to meetings and I was like okay so I was
like out delivering pizza and I went
back and I was like I'm out I'm moving
Hollywood and just from this short these
short films that I had done that got
someone's attention and you know and I
know if the story is ridiculous and then
I was 22 years old and I was plucked
from obscurity but also part of the
story is you know I had these short
films that somebody saw and when he came
to me and said what else do you have I
was able to say well I have this script
that I wrote you know when I gave it to
him and he read that he liked it and so
you know I have a lot of friends who
make short films or you know who as a
calling card which is an amazing calling
card is a short film to get people's
attention and I always tell them like
you have to be prepared for if someone's
cheat your short film and likes it and
then they say what else do you have what
do you have any features like do you
have something you have to be able to
say yes like here is the other thing
because I have a lot of friends who have
this short that they've worked really
hard on and they'll go play a festival
or something and then they'll meet an
agent or a producer and the agent will
say what else do you have
well now I've got some ideas like if
stuff I want to try to start working on
but um nothing right now like you can't
do that you have to have something ready
to go that's my piece of advice when
going back to when you were delivering
pizzas did you actually get the call
while you were on a run like you know so
this is actually a really funny story so
I was I graduated and I was living in
Austin and I was I was moving out of my
apartment because for I was gonna spend
six months living with a friend of mine
in her spare bedroom saving up money
over the summer and into just like I
graduate in May when you graduate and
then I was gonna move in January so I
had like seven months where I was just
gonna deliver a pizza and make money and
so I had to move out of my apartment so
I moved everything out of my apartment
except my answering machine the only
thing that was still in my apartment
because this is before I don't even got
a cell phone yet this is 2001 so I had
an answering machine and when I gave
that agent a business card by the way
still my agent so maybe one day here we
are 16 years later when I gave him a mic
card in Los Angeles the only number that
was on it was my apartment in Austin
because then I have a cell phone so the
only way he had of contacting me was to
call my apartment so I hadn't heard from
him for like two or three months or
whatever I was like oh I guess he never
got mice character didn't read my script
so the only thing left in my apartment
was my answering machine so I went and I
moved to everything over the new place
and then I had to go back clean and then
take the answering machine away so I go
back to clean and there's a red light
blinking on the answering machine and I
was like oh I have a message and a beep
there's a hey Todd it's a Steven from
the counter agency rule II read your
script give me a call
had I had I gotten to my apartment like
an hour earlier and unplug the machine I
just never would have gotten a call from
him who knows if he would have tried to
track me down
by some other means but um but but that
message was waiting for me and the only
thing left in my apartment was that
answering machine so knocking on wood is
that was really lucky but I then got a
cellphone and I stayed in Austin for
like three months delivering pizza
because I still need to save up money to
move to LA cuz just cuz then I had an
agent didn't mean I was like rich or
something I still needed to afford to
move to LA so delivering pizzas saving
up money I bought a cell phone and I
gave it to my agent my agent my new cell
phone number and he took my scripts that
I wrote for class and he get he he gave
me some notes on it and I did a new
draft and then he sent it around town as
a spec script and he showed it to a
bunch of producers and like I didn't
know what that meant and so I'm I'm out
on a delivery in Austin and my phone
rings and it's my Hollywood agent and
he's like Todd hey we went out with your
script and we just set it up at
Paramount at the it was kelsey Grammer's
company at the time Graham net and I was
like oh oh cool like I don't know what
that means what does that mean and he's
like well it's $10,000 option plus
you're gonna get writers guild minimum
of twenty seven thousand to do the
guaranteed rewrite and I was just like
I'm sorry what what he's like yes oh
it's a guaranteed 37 thousand dollars
and I was just like I was like that's
more money than I've ever even heard of
imagining because I'm making like seven
dollars an hour at this piece of clothes
so I was it was like a dream I was like
I couldn't believe it and I went back to
the double Dave's pizza where I worked
and I walked in and I was like I'm out I
quit I'm Hollywood now but then I'm a
nice guy so actually finished my shift
oh that's good I think I even finished
worked one more shifts but then I
but then I quit and then I moved to LA
but that being said I did there and
learn the harsh realities of like I then
it's not like everything I wrote got
sold or I got jobs that easy like I
thought that's how it works because my
first script out the gate like I got
optioned and got a rewrite so I was just
like oh every script I ever write now
it's gonna get optioned and set up but
no it took it took a while for it to
happen again the second time I hit
lightning in a bottle that first time
and I moved out to LA thinking like I'm
a wunderkind I'm an awesome young
hotshot 22 year old and then the harsh
realities of being a working writer
actually set in and I got they got hard
how soon after that oh pretty soon you
know pretty soon like I wrote another
script you know I moved out I wrote
another script I'm like cool let's show
this one I'm sure I'm gonna set this one
up and no one cared feel really nuff now
what else I was like oh and then years I
mean years went by before I actually set
up another one of my own scripts because
you know I learned very quickly that
when you want to be a working writer
it's not like you write scripts and then
go sell them to people most jobs you're
ever gonna work are you writing scripts
for other people based on their ideas or
pre-existing material so it's not like
people are looking for original scripts
as much it is hey we need a writer to
rewrite that draft of the Ninja Turtles
movie or you know we bought the IP for
some 80s cartoon and we need a writer to
write a script for it and so I very
quickly realized like oh I actually have
to work really hard now to go to
meetings and meet producers and try to
get an assignment that's what it's
called - in order to get paid it's so
like right stuff and for years that's
all I did I mean today it's at this day
that's my primary source of income is I
just do assignment work which is a hard
job like you spend half your time trying
to get the next assignment and then the
little free time you do have you try to
work on an original script
that you hopefully can sell to someone
someday I heard you say or maybe it was
your executive producer and an interview
say we will believe it when we have a
Call Sheet yeah every time or so yes
it's been what 6 to 16 years I mean so
my friend Dee Robertson and I we are the
we that puppet short film I made in
college that I wrote and he directed and
then we both moved out to LA 2002 I
think he'd moved out a little earlier
than me but that's when we hatched the
idea of like let's do a feature like a
puppet human buddy cop movie and write
it do it as a feature we came up with
the characters together in the story and
then I wrote the script and the original
plan was like he was gonna direct it
we're gonna go out and make it ourselves
we're gonna raise a little bit of money
and go shoot it and then we realized oh
that's it's very expensive like to make
a puppet movie you have to build every
set because you need puppeteers under
the floorboards so our thought of doing
it is like a cheap little indie like
quit quickly went away and we tried to
set it up at a couple places over the
years but didn't really pan out and so
we put it on the shelf and and for years
people would get interested in it and
Dee and I would always say Dee who's
still heavily involved with the movie
isn't executive producer in the movie
we'd always be like will believe it when
we see a call shade like they would
attach an actor and everyone would get
excited and we were like yeah well
believe when we see a call sheet or they
get a bunch of money like they'd set it
up at a financing company or a
production company we'd be like yeah
we'll believe it when we see a call
sheet
just because year I mean we set it up at
the Henson Company in 2007 and years I
mean nine years went by with a lot of a
lot of times where it would look good
but then that happen and our joke
deionised you up with each other was
always will believe when we see a call
sheet and then one day I get a call that
melissa mccarthy is doing the movie and
they're gonna shoot it and I was like
yeah I'll believe it when I see a call
she like still still and then
like then one day I got an email with a
PDF of happy time murders shooting day
one and I was like oh it's real like
it's really real it's not gonna fall
apart like it's really happening and I
went to set and I got to see these
puppet characters Dee and I had came up
with probably drunk at a bar in 2002 and
these locations like that we had you
know imagined the years ago we're like
oh they built the set and they built all
these puppets and here they are and
they're actually shooting this movie
it's real and we're on set and here we
are but still I was still skeptical
I still like know something Bad's gonna
happen right like a meteors gonna hit
the soundstage still something Bad's
gonna happen like it's still part of me
sitting here with you right now the
movies gonna come out in a couple of
weeks I still think something horrible
is gonna happen like part of me my
pessimist personality is like something
still horrible is gonna happen right but
I've seen billboards and bus ads I've
seen commercials
that's this movie's really happening
it's really coming out unless this is
awesome elaborate prank that you guys
have all been pulling on me which I
would not be surprised it could be a
filk a dick reality darshan we don't
know is it real am I really a puppet you
know I don't know I was not gonna be
surprised if I wake up tomorrow and I
walk out into my living room and I see
my wife and I'm like oh yeah the happy
time murders interview I did yesterday
went really well and my wife's like
what's the happy time murders and I'm
like wait what and then I go to my
computer and it never has existed it's
all been a dream well if you're like
most people myself included I get
nervous when things are kind of going
because if you've had the bottom fall
out of certain things this is a bad sign
like I'm always not just with like
making movies but with anything like if
I get a new router for my Wi-Fi and I
plug it in and it works right away I'm
like what's wrong right this is there's
no way like there's no way there was
this easy
things ever this easy it's going
straight to the White House exactly yes
didn't you write the script in like an
interesting scenario you went to a motel
we have so indeed dni firsts came up
with the the characters like we slowly
came up with the characters and kind of
the loose outline of the plot and then
when I wrote the script when I was like
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to write
the script and then like Dee you're
gonna be kind of like my bounce board
you're gonna be in the room with me and
I'm gonna be able to like run stuff by
you so what we did was right we're gonna
get a hotel room and I'm gonna sit at
the laptop and you're gonna just like be
in the room like pacing or doing
whatever it is you're doing and and
helping me and so we went on online and
we just found the cheapest hotel room we
could possibly find which is by LAX and
it was like a quality inn
and it was like $39 and remember the
only food we had this grand vision of
being bohemian artists so we're gonna go
right in the hotel and then you show up
and it's just the saddest LAX hotel and
the only food anywhere near there was
there was an ampm where we could go get
coffee and there was a subway like a
24-hour subway that we would go eat at
but we holed up in this hotel for I
think it was one night and then we sat
in the lobby like we had to check out at
a certain time simply sat in the lobby
of the hotel across the street and we
just begged at like I begged out a first
draft I mean it wasn't good but I mean
it was Syria it was like 75 pages in 24
hours or something like that just
writing just writing just writing and it
was pretty awesome Deanna we should go
back to that hotel just like the night
of the premiere yeah we should do an
after-party in that sad little LAX hotel
room what were there moments there that
you're like what are we doing this is
this is like we're almost living out a
write or sort of fantasy out of an 80s
movie yeah I mean as a writer you always
have this vision of like what writers
are supposed to do
so and I've even done it since like I've
my jam now as I'd love to get a hotel if
I happen if like I'm on a deadline I'll
get a hotel room for a day they were for
a night and I'll just stay up all night
writing or I was written a novel a few
years ago and when I did the second
draft of it I got a room in Palm Springs
for like a week and I just went out
there for a week and a couple times I've
had I've been on deadline for a script
like on an assignment and I'm like oh I
was supposed to write the script over
the last eight weeks and I haven't
started it yet so I'm just gonna go get
a hotel room for a week but I did have a
grand vision of like oh you're supposed
to drink while writing right like isn't
that what her stimming way did so I did
buy like a big bottle of whiskey and put
it on the table and I'm like okay here
we go I'm gonna start writing and then I
don't have a drink and one drink and I'm
like I don't want to write anymore I
want to just sit on that big comfortable
bed and watch a movie so I can't do that
I think some people can like drink
whiskey while they write because that's
what writers are supposed to do right I
can't I just lose it like I have I have
one sip of whiskey and I'm like I want
to do anything other than this right now
what about a nice hotel versus a seedy
motel cuz one you kind of think like you
get your brain gets trick that life is
good and safe and the other one you
realize like there's a desperation to
some of it well there between a seedy
motel or a nice motel the only thing the
only thing that's important is that you
go someplace incredibly boring so that
there's nothing tempting you to do
anything else and you know one time I
wanted to work on a script so I went to
like the Glendale Hilton hmm in
beautiful Glendale California just
because I knew there was nothing around
there to walk to to that that would be
that would tempt me to like go to
someplace because everything around
there was like offices that closed down
and so I was like oh great
and even when I've gone to Palm Springs
I remember one time I did I like doing
the the Travelocity secret deal like
where you don't know where you're
staying
you just know the price of it because
you can often say someplace cool for
like half the price because you're
basically promising to stay there no
matter what
so I remember once I had to go for like
a week to write a script and it was the
fall was like October and so I go and
Travelocity secret deal and they're like
you can stay at a five-star resort in
Palm Springs for like 70 bucks a night
and I was like okay so I did it but you
know the secret deal you have to agree
to pay no matter what they can tell you
you're staying at the fleabag motel and
you have to stay there I mean it has to
at least be the star rating that you
signed up for but anyway so you because
you pay ahead of time you have to pay
before you even know where you're
staying so anyway so I did it and they
put me at the Riviera and Palm Springs
which is like a cool retro like 1960s
resume hotel so I show up and it's
October and I walk in and I was like hey
there we go welcome mr. Berger you're
here four or five days I see and I'm
like yeah what's important I'm here to
write like I had my laptop and I'm here
to write for five days so I need to make
sure my room has a desk in it because I
don't want to be stuck in a room that
doesn't have a desk i meter right and
they're like oh well actually our only
rooms with desks are like back in tower
four which doesn't have a view of the
pool is actually not by the pool I'm
like that's fine I have no desire to go
to the pool I'm not getting in the pool
like well it's also not near the fitness
center or the bar and that's fine I
don't want to be near any of the cool
stuff I just want a nice quiet room that
has a desk in it okay cool well just so
you know you're gonna be the only person
in Tower four and I was like perfect so
busy like the shining for a week because
I was literally the only person an
entire wing of this resort and it was
October in Palm Springs which is like
the windy season so you'd be sitting
there like working and you just hear
like howling winds outside and like
trees smashing up against the window and
you would go walk around these big
spooky totally empty hallways and it was
pretty awesome
and I've tried to replicate it but it's
never worked out it was a magical time
but I highly recommend that going to
Palm Springs in the off season because
it's super cheap because nobody's there
like when it's everyone goes for the
summer like to go in pools but go to
Palm Springs in like October November
and nobody's there it's great hole up
someplace it's magic well part of the
screenwriting process would you say
you're the best at and maybe then not so
great like are you great at the first
draft but not so great at rewrites or
maybe it's the opposite I definitely I
would say I'm I'm really good first Jeff
let's say I'm really good at plotting
like I really I figured out the
mathematical formula to like a plot of a
movie and being able to figure out
exactly when everything should happen
because really when you think about it
writing a movie especially Hollywood
movies like I know there are movies that
break the formula but it is all math
it's all a mathematical formula and you
need certain things that happen on
certain pages and the inciting incident
needs to come around here and you need
you know emotional character journeys to
kind of happen on here and you need this
and that any other thing so I feel like
I'm really good at figuring out a plot
and then figuring how it all goes down
my weak spot definitely on the first
draft is like why are any of these
characters doing this or like why don't
we care about them you know like what
are the emotional journeys like of the
characters sometimes I I think of almost
being secondary like I'm such a plot
person that I love to figure out like
what actually happens in this movie from
a B to C like how does it start what is
the middle what is the end but then I
have writer friends who are totally
character people who they think of the
character first and the entire backstory
of that character and what happens with
that character's emotional journey and
then they figure out the plot of the
movie you know like I'm the opposite I
think of the plot of the movie and then
I figure out who are these characters
really
what do they want what are their
emotional journeys and that's what I
figure out like in the rewrites like
that's what I go back in but I'm super
OCD and like I won't finish a script I
won't if I start a script I have to
finish it like I won't do anything else
and you know I'll write an outline
number 1 to 100 well just number page
100 and I'm like what happens on every
this is every minute of the movie this
is every page what happens on every and
every minute of this movie on page 1
this is what happens page 15 this is
what happens page 82 this is what
happens page 100 this is the last scene
and I'll fill in all those gaps and I'll
put it on my desk I'll print it up
actually print it I'll put it on my desk
and then I'll start writing I'm gonna be
like you know I'm like I'm not gonna be
happy until I've gotten through all 100
pages and I will just spend I'll ignore
all other aspects of my life I won't go
out I won't do anything and we'll go see
movies I'll just work on I'll wake up at
6:30 in the morning and I'll work on it
until my brains fried I can't work on it
anymore
and I'll just do that until I have a
first draft and the first draft often
sucks but at least it's done and then
you can set it aside take some time off
of it
and then come back to it and the rewrite
is the fun part for me do you always
know what's going to happen on line 100
I mean are you--oh is the end of it
always sort of clear yeah the first
thing I do is I write down page 1 what
happens on page 1 what happens on beach
30 let's see in the first act
that's your inciting incident like that
is your movie right it's what happens on
page 30 is if you were to go see a
trailer for the movie page 30 is the
thing it's in the trailer right and then
I write down what happens on page 100
like how does that look what does the I
need to know where this is going and
then I figure how do we get there so and
then you fill in all the holes you know
you've you know on page 80 issues like
the end of the second act like dark of
night like what's gone really bad for
everybody like why is this Nina
second there and then you fill in all
those holes in between but I like to I
like to come up with really cool endings
really cool third acts like and then
move backwards in a way like I want to
know where this is all going and how it
ends I feel like a lot of people a lot
of writers spend a lot of time on their
first act and then and and and when you
see a lot of movies the first acts are
really awesome and then they just kind
of don't know what to do with it like
they have a really good idea that they
don't know what to do with it what I
strive really hard to think about the
second half of the movie and then to a
fault
like often people's criticisms of my
work is like yeah your first act is
really meandering or like really long
but your second half is great so I try
to focus on the second half of the movie
but you know the hard part being a
writer is most people don't even get to
the second half of that movie when
they're reading your script they read
the first ten pages and your first ten
pay their pages better blow them away
whereas I often believe in like the slow
burn of a first act of like take it
really slow and let stuff develop which
is to my detriment often but I'm getting
better I'm getting better at it let's
suppose you finish the because you had
this thing where you want to finish
something and I think that's great but
let's suppose you finish it and then
eventually you go back to it you're like
I'm not really into it do you just leave
it alone but the fact that you finished
it was what was mainly important to you
I often I'll always want to get it to a
point where I can show it to other
people like I've never written anything
I've never done a first draft of
anything and been like yeah like I'm
glad I wrote this but I'm never gonna
show it to anyone because I feel like
you never know when you're gonna meet a
person who wants to do the exact thing
that you had written five years ago so I
always want to get a script to the place
where I would feel comfortable showing
it to someone else if it ever came up
like I don't show it to people but I
would show it like I would read it I
would be happy with a show it's like my
wife just to make sure it makes sense
and help me look for typos
and then I'm happy to put it on a shelf
and never show it to anybody unless one
day I'm in a meeting one day I'm at a
barbecue did someone's like yeah I'm a
producer I uh my brother owns a
furniture store in Arizona and I'd love
I can get two free location and I have
half a million dollars and if I can find
a movie set in a furniture store
I can shoot there and that's when I'm
able to say funny I have a thriller that
I wrote setting a furniture store five
years ago no one's ever seen it
no one's ever read it I just wrote it
because I wanted to write it it's like a
story I wanted to tell but I was very
aware that there's no market for half a
million dollar furniture store movies
but then who knows happy time murders
you know Dee Roberts um um I came up
with these characters came up with a
story I wrote the script we try to get
it made for fun we just want to do it
for fun like and didn't happen put it on
the shelf years later we weren't doing
anything with it it was just sitting on
the shelf the virtual shelf of my
computer my agent calls me he says hey
the Jim Henson Company called me because
they're starting a new division called
Henson alternative and they're looking
to do adults oriented puppet stuff and
they wanted to do they called me
basically like we want to develop an
r-rated puppet movie do you have any
writers who you think would be good fit
to do that
and my agent said well actually I have a
client who already wrote an r-rated
puppet movie it's called a happy time
murderers he wrote it like five years
ago and they were like what so he sent
it over and they read it they're like oh
yeah great let's do this this is exactly
what we wanted but we had already done
it just for fun so that's always been my
my method it's just like I write stuff
for fun that I like and then I put it on
the shelf and maybe one day it'll come
up in conversation and someone will want
to make it who knows what makes it in
our rating well what are these puppets
doing that are so that's so adult
oriented
they they're it's sex drugs violence
rock-and-roll the puppets are doing
everything that people do in their
everyday life but we're finally seeing
what the puppets do behind closed doors
what the puppets do in the streets how
the puppets actually talk to each other
you know I often even you know I often
have I've written a bunch of family
stuff and I've been written a bunch of
PG movies but I've also like well like
the movies I've directed have always
been are and they're always filled with
cursing and you know adult themes and
people have asked me like well why do
you why do you have these characters
like cursing all the time and I'm like
because that's how people talk like my
friends when we're hanging out that's
how we talk you know and when you want
to make a movie about a certain kind of
person like they curse a lot like they
drop f-bombs or this is how they talk to
each other and when we set out to make a
movie about the actual like what if
there wasn't actually a world where
puppets and humans coexisted with each
other and the puppets were like this
underclass of society that were you know
sugar addicts and like living on the
streets and like we're this underclass
like they would actually it would be
pretty rough like and they would talk to
each other in pretty rough ways and it
would be it would be a really
interesting world to explore and the
thing about the funny thing about
r-rated comedies is that there's a lot
of movies you see there's this very fine
line between pg-13 and are right and so
it's very easy to take a script and be
like why don't we just make this pg-13
all you got to do is cut some f-bombs
out of it but but if you are going to
commit to making an r-rated movie a lot
of times studios or production companies
will say if this is gonna be our let's
make it our like let's go for it
you know like because why not like we've
already committed to appealing to a
certain kind of audience that wants to
see an r-rated comedy and we've
alienated anyone under the age of 60 and
who can
go see it unless they're with a parent
or guardian so we might as well go for
it you know like there's no point in
making an r-rated comedy that's gonna
have like one or two f-bombs and that's
why it's are like why like let's just go
for and get nuts and like let's show the
sorted private lives of puppets and all
the shenanigans they get up to you know
you had said if you're gonna go are ya
like kind of go big or go home
right so to speak and I was reading a
Judy Blume novel that was specifically
for adults oh how bad could this be and
a basically first page in I'm like oh
wow yeah yeah there's a reason yeah yeah
so were there scenes that you had to
like amp up in terms of it wasn't our
enough well yeah I mean when we we set
it up when I set up at the Henson
Company we had conversations as because
we read it as a hard-r like you know we
came up with this idea and I wrote the
script to be hard are when we set up at
the Jim Henson Company we had
conversations of should we make this
pg-13 like are we a lien ating a segment
of the audience like if it is our but
you know this is the mid-2000s and and
like you know South Park was incredibly
popular and Ted came out and people left
afternoon cue and there was definitely a
market for r-rated entertainment that
like twisted the tropes of children's
entertainment and you know when we set
the movie up at STX STX was like no no
no this is gonna be our and we almost if
we almost want it to be super our so
that we wanted to make it very clear
this is not a kid's movie like we want
to embrace the dark twisted part of it
and we want to totally explore that we
totally want to go down that road and we
want to make sure parents know that this
is an r-rated movie that is not for your
children so even part of the ad campaign
I mean is like them making it very clear
to people this is not a children's movie
do not take your children too
movie and so we never we never like no
one ever said like hey are it up like we
really want you to make this we want you
to add stuff that's just for you know
gross out factors or anything that but
we were we were always welcome it was
always understood like no no we want
this to be our we're totally fine with
it
and if anything like we want everyone to
know that because we don't want anyone
accidentally bringing like a
seven-year-old into this movie so
because you know I'd seen a lot of
r-rated comedies where it was clear like
there was a studio note at some point
that said we need some sequence that's
just there to be gross you know this is
a gross a comedy
we need there's something that has like
nothing to do with the plot or the story
or the characters that we just need to
throw in there but we never really
encountered that I mean people were
always like the the nature of the story
and the characters itself is our and
everything that happens to everybody is
our so it kind of worked cohesively
rather than we need it we need something
here that's gonna be crude just for
crude sake do you think you're a better
writer when you're going through happy
times in your life or when maybe things
are a little bit uncertain and you think
that's when you're more creative I think
you're always kind of the same writer no
matter what mood you're in but what
you're writing about changes and I think
you know everything we write says
something about something right and
whether it says something about the
human condition or the world and if I'm
in a happier times if I'm in better
moods I'm probably writing something
that is more specifically positive or
celebrating the good things about
humanity but if I'm in a darker place if
I'm sad or if I'm upset I'm probably
writing something that is more a biting
satire of the bad parts of the human
condition but probably the writing
levels are the same like I don't think
me being
you know me being in a bad place or
something makes me a better writer and I
definitely don't think you know artists
don't need to suffer in order to make
good art you know but I think what you
are making art about definitely probably
changes and depending on what you're
experiencing at any given moment
we had this comment come in from Milly
purpose how do you know people will
laugh or share and have sort of the same
humor that you will have I mean you
never know when people are gonna find
funny what you find funny and you never
know when they're gonna laugh what you
laugh it but sometimes I don't care like
to me I'm just trying to do something
that I think it's funny
and I hope with fingers crossed that
other people are gonna find it to find
it funny too and you know there are
certain jobs I'll take where I try to
like if I'm gonna write a kids movie I
should get into the head of a kid like
what would I thought was funny if I was
a kid if I was seven years old like what
I find this funny
but when I write when I'm most unbridle
and I'm writing a comedy when I just
want to write something really funny I
just think about what would I Todd
burger find really funny and and if
other people find it funny great if they
don't well that's on them maybe they
need a better sense of humor you know
but you never know and like you can't I
think as a comedy writer you can't try
to get in the heads of other people and
think what they're gonna think it's
funny
you have to just write what you think is
funny and you'll find out later I mean I
read stuff in happy time murders that I
thought was really funny and then we had
a test screening of the movie people did
not think that that joke was funny I
thought it was really funny or the
opposite there'd be something that I
didn't think was very funny then people
thought was hilarious and you're like oh
you never know like you never know if
people are gonna find funny you just
hope you hit more than you miss and and
hope that people are on the same page
with you but really we should all be
just we should all be writing movies
that we want to watch we should be the
target audience of the movie and even if
you're writing a kid's movie you should
want to write a movie that you would
want to take your kids to or if you were
a kid you would have wanted to watch and
and yeah so like you should be your own
audience that's a bumper sticker yeah we
should all be our own audience that's
probably like a Netflix slogan we don't
know about be your own audience